Here is one way in which
an intelligent agent can work and
accomplish environment with a large
number of perception actions possible
and yet do so relatively efficiently.
Suppose that this 2 to
the power n percepts,
could be mapped into k concepts
where each of these k concept
is an equivalence class with a large
number of these combinations.
So 2 to the power of n may be very, very
large, but k is a much smaller number.
So these concepts are now equivalence
classes or these percepts.
So now instead of indexing my actions
on the combinations of percepts,
I index my actions on the equivalence
classes that are called concepts, and
this happens all the time.
You go to a doctor, for example and you
may go with some signs and symptoms and
the doctor says, well, I have to decide
whether I'll give you a blue liquid or
a red liquid, assume that those
are the actions possible.
And the actions are now indexed,
not as the signs and symptoms or
the combination of signs and symptoms,
which are potentially very large for
human beings, but it's a small number
of concepts, the number of diseases,
which compared to all the combinations
of signs and symptoms, is much smaller.
>> Another example of this that
would come from computer programming
would be that we might have a small
number of different ways in which
a computer program can go wrong,
by a large number of different percepts
that tell us what has
actually gone wrong.
So, for example in my percepts, I might
have whether or not I received a null
pointer error, whether or not I received
a memory allocation error, whether or
not I received an index larger
than size of an array error.
All of those are different percepts
I might have, but it might map
the same underlying concept or something
that has not yet been initialized.
So I'm taking the number of things that
I can actually see and mapping them to
a smaller number of ways in which
the program can actually go wrong.
Then instead of having to map each
individual percept to some number of
actions, I know that if my error is
that something has not been initialized
I need to find what hasn't
been initialized and
there's a much smaller list of
actions involved looking at each
individual variable and seeing where
the initialization has not taken place.
>> Now we understand
why classification is
such an often-studied topic
in artificial intelligence.
Almost every school of artificial
intelligence has studied
classification extensively.
If there were no concept we were
mapping this two to the power
n combinations of percepts and use two
to the power m combinations of actions,
then we could think of an intelligent
agent as one large, giant table.
The rows of the table are all the two
to the n combinations of percepts
that will be that many rows and the
columns are through the power m actions.
Given a percept, I know exactly what
action to take if they would tell you
that, and
it's going to be a very large table.
We don't know how to use it,
it will be very costly to use it, and
we don't know how to build such a table.
What classification is doing is,
it is breaking that large table
into a large number of small tables,
and that's the power of knowledge.
When you have knowledge,
you can take some complex problem, and
break it into a large number of smaller,
simpler problems.